Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This paper reveals us a fundamental difference
between how humans and machines learn.
Imagine the following situation: you are given
a video game with no instructions, you start
playing it, and the only information you get
is a line of text when you successfully finished
the game.
That's it!
So far, so good, this is relatively easy to
play because the visual cues are quite clear:
the pink blob looks like an adversary, and
what the spikes do is also self-explanatory.
This is easy to understand, so we can finish
the game in less than a minute.
Easy!
Now, let's play this.
Whoa!
What is happening?
Even empty space looks like as if it were
a solid tile.
I am not sure if I can finish this version
of the game, at least not in a minute for
sure.
So, what is happening here is that some of
artwork of the objects has been masked out.
As a result, this version of the game is much
harder to play for humans.
So far, this is hardly surprising, and if
that would be it, this wouldn't have been
a very scientific experiment.
However, this is not the case.
So to proceed from this point, we will try
to find what makes humans learn so efficiently,
but not by changing everything at once, but
by trying to change and measure only one variable
at a time.
How about this version of the game?
This is still manageable, since the environment
remains the same, only the objects we interact
with have been masked.
Through trial and error, we can find out the
mechanics of the game.
What about reversing the semantics?
Spikes now became tasty ice cream, and the
shiny gold conceals an enemy that eats us.
Very apt, I have to say.
Again, with this, the problem suddenly became
more difficult for humans as we need some
trial and error to find out the rules.
After putting together several other masking
strategies, they measured amount of time,
the number of deaths and interactions that
were required to finish the level.
I will draw your attention mainly to the blue
lines which show which variable caused how
much degradation in the performance of humans.
The main piece of insight is not only that
these different visual cues throw off humans,
but it tells us variable by variable, and
also, by how much.
An important insight here is that highlighting
important objects and visual consistency are
key.
So what about the machines?
How are learning algorithms affected?
These are the baseline results.
Adding masked semantics?
Barely an issue.
Masked object identities?
This sounds quite hard, right?
Barely an issue.
Masked platforms and ladders?
This is a remarkable property of learning
algorithms, as they don't only think in terms
of visual cues, but in terms of mathematics
and probabilities.
Removing similarity information throws the
machines off a bit, which is understandable,
because the same objects may appear as if
they were completely different.
There is more analysis on this in the paper,
so make sure to have a look.
So, what are the conclusions here?
Humans are remarkably good at reusing knowledge,
and reading and understanding visual cues.
However, if the visual cues become more cryptic,
their performance drastically decreases.
When machines start playing the game, at first,
they have no idea which character they control,
how gravity works or how to defeat enemies,
or that keys are required to open doors.
However, they learn these tricky problems
and games much easier and quicker, because
these mind-bending changes, as you remember,
are barely an issue.
Note that you can play the original and the
obfuscated versions on the author's website
as well.
Also note that we really have only scratched
the surface here, the paper contains a lot
more insights.
So, it is the perfect time to nourish your
mind with a paper, so make sure to click it
in the video description and give it a read.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!